das süd chemie del ist und bleibt eine
projektionsfläche gerade verschäft
steller die die exotische kulisse für
ihre geschichte wählen am mythos südsee
arbeiten sich auch schweizer literaten
ab jeder auf seine weise von der sitze
im bild eines schweizer malers über
einen heiligen der kokosnuss bis zur
schatzsuche auf den spuren von robert
louis stevenson alex caffi versucht ein
realistisches bild zu zeichnen der
südsee zu zeiten von stephenson
so hat gab die südsee selbst erlebt
komplementärfarben auch heute wird jeder
zuwanderer irgendwann auch die
schattenseiten entdecken gibt musik und
wenn sie fehler machen damit als roth
ganz normal läuft und sich selber york
mit genau das ist raum für jeden
immigranten und dazu das klima
anstrengende körperliche viele alte
schnell für die linke und starb
fünf jahre lang hat alex caffi für
seinen roman recherchiert und jeden
sommer in der südsee verbracht dabei
hatte auch das leben abseits des mythos
kennenlernt ein leben das zwar auf uns
fremdartig wirkt aber nicht paradiesisch
ist
behilflich far cry ist und in seiner
eigenen jetzt viel kreuz benny wirkliche
freunde etc aber schon dass sie wirklich
ganz andere situation als die elitäre
verstorbene ihrem haus eine begraben
unter dem fußboden und nach einer
glücklich mit denen verstorbene zweimal
aber dass ich frei so fremd und
immofinanz moment abstoßend und mitte
sitzt und dass er normalität aber allein
getötet lang der ok die liebe sucht die
sitze ist immer gleich blau
doch die literarischen geschichten
spielen in ihren eigenen
vorstellungswelten kritisch und
distanziert
ganz anders die popkultur sie verlangt
nach postkarten idylle und
identifizierung die intec procter 50er
jahre benannt nach dem götterfiguren der
polynesier die für die mode stilbildend
waren
man trug hawaiihemd und lauschten der
ukulele und am palm dach des heimischen
cocktail keller oder in bars wie dem
trader vix was anderen heute peinlich
ist sven kirsten sammelt es
die südsee verkörperte für die menschen
das verlorene paradies
die leute hatten gerade einen
schrecklichen krieg hinter sich und
brauchten fluchtmöglichkeiten und und
iggy pop kultur bietet einfach einen
tollen eskapismus und eine super flucht
welt um sich von den dem stress des
alltags oder auch der geschichte die
vorher passiert war zu erholen
die schweizer fanden ihre sitze auf
wochenmärkten von aarau bis zollikofen
bei hawaii journey mit seiner steel
guitar den plastik bürgerwillen um den
hals und der sonne im herzen
bis die 68er kann
da wurde alles was mit dem eltern leben
zu tun hatte verpönt und auf den
scheiterhaufen geworfen und titel
gehörte dazu seit über 30 jahren ist das
bild der südsee in der popkultur jetzt
schon verblasst in der literatur lebt
dagegen der mythos sitze noch immer denn
hier ist sie mehr als flucht oder
gegenwelt sie eröffnet eigene
literarische räume möglichkeit welten
unabhängig von der wirklichkeit führt
über die südsee roman weht auch ferien
sie aber nie lebensmittelpunkt wenn wir
eigentlich im monat maßnahmen luft paris
oder ruft berlin oder was sie wirklich
filmmacher derzeit bessere note auf der
war das alter wo liebe 40 tonner himmels
richtige hat einen ort der volvo ce der
südsee bin hier einfach zweimal zwölf
stunden unterwegs egal weil die dichte
und es geht in europa völlig hauptstadt
von samoa gibt es kino knapp und eine
mcdonald's und zu muss man wirklich mit
der palme und mit nemo fische im wasser
und mit dem sandstrand friede sie
was sind schon die schönsten träumen und
sandstrände gegen die ganze welt vor der
haustür
zumindest als möglichkeit
schon der uns geschaffen als biologin